- Were you able to perform
on stage at all this summer?
- Yes.
You know so I went out
to yellow Springs Ohio,
to Dave Chappelle's.
Dave Chappelle has a, like
a summer camp going on.
Where it's performances that are COVID.
You know everybody is socially distanced
or physically distanced.
- Yeah.
- However you want to say it.
And people, we all get COVID tested.
It's great comedians.
I mean, I've from Sarah Silverman,
then Tiffany Haddish, to my
man Muhammad to Dave himself
it's like some of the best comedians.
Michael Che, Jon Hamm was out there.
We had a great time,
but we also performed Questlove
from the roots Erykah Badu.
And it felt so great to be on stage.
It's like you remember the joy
of what it is when you're on stage.
Like not only the joy for you,
but the joy you able to give people.
I think that's,
I mean I don't know for you,
- Yeah.
but for me being on stage
is like you sharing a gift.
- it's you're the vessel.
- Your the vessel
and you receive energy from the crowd,
but you also give energy.
So it was just a blessing to be there,
we all were like energized
by getting on stage.
- Were y'all all on it.
Like this is my dream movie
of all the people that you just said.
So were we you all on stage
at certain points together?
Like doing stuff together.
- Yeah we were together
because as soon as we
arrived in yellow Springs,
you get COVID tests.
And so at that point we
get our little wristband
- Am getting the band.
and I'm good.
And everybody feels a
little more comfortable.
It's you know it's a
transition for people because,
you know we all coming from the world
where we like wearing a mask,
but once we got COVID tested,
it's a small amount of people that around.
And you know, but it's a great crowd.
Like everybody and people come
from all over the Midwest.
Mostly Ohio and Yellow
Springs is a great town.
Shout out to yellow Springs.
I love this town.
(crowd cheering)
It's like a hippie town
in the middle of Ohio,
small place and Dave is like the mirror.
- Very artistic.
- Yeah it's very artistic.
- Yeah.
I bought Palo Santo
and different little antique things there.
I love it.
- That's so cool.
And what a, what a way to
navigate what's going on.
- Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
Like for it not to
completely stop everyone
and their creativity and their expression
and inspiring people.
That's, that's a really,
really cool way to do that.